let's go to Dan from Illinois Dan from
Illinois welcome to the David packman
show what's on your mind today
hi David can you hear me yes I can
oh I'm so glad you picked me um before I
get to my question I wanted to
congratulate you on having such an
excellent show
um I've been a viewer for a couple years
now and I think the reason why I've
become a daily viewer of yours is
because the quality of what you do uh
and the degree to which you think
through and present things is so above
and beyond what is out there wow well I
appreciate that yes and specifically if
I could uh if I could if I could say I
think the thing that's most valuable to
me is when you do very specific
breakdowns that that delve into issues
very deeply a lot of what's out there in
the media especially corporate media it
doesn't it doesn't really help people
understand complex issues and I love
what you do
so well I appreciate that very much Dan
thank you
absolutely encourage you to continue on
that and so that that being said the
question that I have is um about
something that you and I agree on okay
that you that you've talked about
but I haven't heard you go more in depth
and so you've talked about the
importance of media literacy yes
um and I would love to hear your
thoughts on I guess both ways like if
you could weigh the magic wand how would
you approach media literacy but also
maybe like what would fit into reality
because
um I mean I could speak to them where
I'll I'll let you answer well as I've
said before I think that really you
really want to be teaching media
literacy as young as people start
consuming media now how do you teach a
two-year-old who watches cartoons media
literacy well you know you start to
distinguish commercials from the
programming I think right I mean you
start very simple but as a matter of
school curriculum
certainly by sixth grade there should be
just it should be standard that we're
teaching media literacy understanding
the difference between news and opinion
understanding the impact of you know
advertisers product placement just
because you saw something on TV or on
the Internet does it mean it's true
what's the different all of this basic
stuff the earlier you arm people with
tools needed the less that they're ever
going to fall for Fox News or Newsmax
and it's sort of like it's sort of like
a vaccine against disinformation so I
would like to see it just be a standard
part of school curriculum starting
probably I used to say seventh grade now
I'm probably more at like sixth grade
maybe even fifth
I I couldn't agree more
um I think that this is actually a core
of what is causing many many issues uh
because it's so easy for anyone to say
anything yes
um and just understanding sort of the
psychology of media how it affects
people there's uh a lot of people using
it in you know nefarious ways
self-serving ways and uh for for my
vantage point that's sort of feeling
like I'm watching things we're sort of
sliding off of a cliff with 100 uh
without that sense of how are we going
to come back from this are do you have
any voices or books or resources that
you've looked to in terms of uh people
who are kind of have expertise in that
that has informed your sense of like how
that could actually be done or how we
could actually look to do that not from
a policy standpoint you know on my book
recommendation list on my website I have
tons of books about thinking that I
recommend but none of them are policy
oriented in that way uh but I'll look
around and see if there are any
awesome well thank you so much that
answers uh what I wanted to talk to you
about so all right Dan from Illinois
very much appreciate the call we're
going to take more calls but let's take
a very quick break and then we'll be
back if you're holding on to talk to me
don't hang up because we're going right
back to the phones